yeah i'm just here for the good vibes
trying to
think a bit more
freely about my position
hope i'm not interrupting
another goody asses story time but
because i'm sure has plenty but uh
yeah
i thought i have promising attack this
is d5 c4 idm probably some
underestimated this but uh
i mean like g4 might miss the point but
i thought
you should go for something like c6
c5 was also possible to
you know ask if i would want to take on
c6 but uh
maybe i don't want to
uh but after an idea for this here i
mean of course
he has
some sort of attack on my king but
because i cover the third rank
i don't feel it's enough after i go like
queen e1 b6 would be five at any time i
can come with my other route to a3
covers knight on f3
and
uh well of course b4 will be
on my mind always so
i feel like i had good i have a good
position now but of course there's still
a lot of things that i need to do right
in the next few moves
confident about his attacking chances
maximum shared